republicana no voy a comenzar con una
pequeña historias acerca de una
embajadora de las naciones unidas y de
un discurso que ya vio en esta
convención y pidió para reelección del
presidente start y llamó a su país
esta embajadora dijo los demócratas
siempre cumplan a estados unidos primero
el año 1989 presentaron al rey y el
embajador son a las palabras del
embajador son reales hoy en día hay
derechos demócratas aún culpa en eeuu
primero
donald trump siempre apuesto eeuu
primero y él ha ganado cuatro años más
como presidente y fue un honor de la
vida servir como la embajadora de eeuu
en las naciones unidas así que las
naciones unidas
es un lugar donde los dictadores
asesinos y ladrones denuncian estados
unidos y luego demandan que nosotros les
paguemos sus cuentas reciente trump le
puso fin a todo eso con su liderazgo
nosotros hicimos lo que barack obama y
joe biden se negaron a ser mis
defendimos a eeuu y nos defendimos de
nuestros enemigos obama y biden dejan
que corea del norte amenazara eeuu el
presidente camps rechazó esa debilidad y
pasamos las sanciones más difíciles en
la historia a corear norte obama y
vaivén dejaron que se salieran con los
asesinatos y les enviaron dinero
el presidente trombo
rompió con el acuerdo iraní
el presidente se movió nuestra embajada
a jerusalén y cuando las naciones unides
nosotros fue orgullosos declarar el veto
de eeuu en esa votación
es bueno para iraní para crisis bueno
para la china
y quiere que eeuu siempre se disculpe y
abandonen nuestros valores
donald trump s ni fuerte con china acabó
con isis y ganó y le dice al mundo lo
que necesita escuchar
en nuestro hogar el presidente es la
opción correcta para la economía y los
trabajos mientras que yo bailé en lo que
ha hecho es retrasar a eeuu
yo era gobernadora de carolina del sol
en las manufacturas llegaron a todas
partes del mundo creando miles de
trabajos para los estadounidenses mucha
gente
llamaban caroline al sur como las
bestias
nosotros reducimos los impuestos ellos
lo aumentaron y nosotros cuando nosotros
hicimos buenos trabajos creamos los
trabajos vice de obama nos demandaron yo
me defendí y ellos se rindieron
bailén jarvis una administración de ebay
de mijares sería mucho peor la última
vez
el jefe de badén era obama parecería
sanders pelosi y su cuadrilla ellos se
basa en el socialismo y sabemos que el
socialismo ha fallado en todas partes
ellos quieren decirle a eeuu cómo vivir
como pensar y quieren que el gobierno se
encargue de la salud
quieren destruir millones de trabajos
quieren una granja cobra una cantidad de
impuestos
socialista-radical de ellos sería un
error
el presidente trompo lidera una nueva
era antes de que china nos diera el
coronavirus nosotros estábamos rompiendo
los récords económicos la pandemia nos
ha un poco pero no por mucho
tiempo el presidente
trump va a lograr volverla a resurgir
hay un área muy importante donde nuestro
presidente es lo correcto él sabe
en mucho del partido democrático es
común decir que eeuu es racista eso es
una mentira eeuu no es un país racista
esto es personal para mí yo soy la hija
de inmigrantes de la india
mi padre usa un turbante mi madre nos
avanzar y yo
era una pequeña niña y nos enfrentamos a
discriminación pero mis padres nunca se
dieron ante el odio mi madre hizo un
negocio exitoso mi padre
fue profesor en una escuela y me
escogieron a mí como la gobernadora
primera mujer gobernadora y de la
minoría de eeuu y es un trabajo un
progreso
hay que seguir con este progreso hay que
hacerla más libre y mejor para todo el
mundo y más justa es por eso que es muy
triste ver al partido demócrata ser y
hacerse los ciegos frente a los
disturbios y las protestas
es claro que nosotros valoramos a todas
las personas incluso los
afrodescendientes de descendientes
incluso los policías afrodescendientes a
todos los trabajadores y empresarios
afrodescendientes también a los niños
afrodescendientes también sus vidas
son importantes
no debe ser así
así no eras de 5 años en carolina del
sur
nuestro estado se enfrentó frente al mar
una persona entró en un estudio de
biblia 12 personas rezaron con él por
una hora él empezó luego a disparar
después de esa tragedia
no nos pusimos una en contra de otros
nos unimos blancos y negros demócratas y
republicanos tomamos las decisiones
difíciles para poder sanar y avanzar de
una forma pacífica pacífica y respeto' y
de manera respetuosa y eso nos da
esperanza ahora eeuu no es perfecto pero
los principales que tenemos son
perfectos si hay algo que he aprendido
es que nuestro peor día nosotros somos
bendecidos por vivir en eeuu es tiempo
de mantener estado en bendición para el
resto de las generaciones este
presidente y este partido están
comprometidos con esta tarea buscamos
una nación que resurge junta y no que
cae en la energía
sabemos que la única forma de
sobreponernos a los retos es darle la
bienvenida a las fortalezas de eeuu
estamos buscando donde un futuro
brillante donde todas las personas y
todos niños van a una buena escuela
donde viven en una comunidad segura con
buenos trabajos donde los empresarios y
emprendedores pueden buscar sus sueños
donde cualquier soñador puede trabajar y
donde todas las vidas son protegidas
cualquier niña y niño mujer y hombre de
cualquier religión y raza para tener la
mejor oportunidad y la mejor el mejor
tipo de vida en esta elección debemos
elegir al único candidato que ha tenido
y que va a continuar
liderando esta visión el presidente
camps y el vicepresidente page tienen mi
apoyo y eeuu tienen nuestras promesas
vamos a construir el progreso nuestro
pasado y continuar
haciendo las promesas del futuro
y buscando la reelección de donald trump
gracias y que dios siempre bendiga a
estados unidos
[Música]